let's talk about this uh we got uh from
cbs denver
denver attorney files civil action in
kyle written house shooting now before i
actually read what it's about i want to
stress i was browsing reddit earlier and
there's a tweet from a guy not even a
link to the story they don't even have
decency to actually post the link they
post a screenshot of a tweet not even a
link to the tweet no decency to even put
the tweet post the tweet link and the
guy says
breaking news the first civil lawsuits
in the rittenhouse trial have been filed
and all of the comments are saying
things like
kyle rittenhouse is going to lose this
lawsuit because civil lawsuits are
easier to win than criminal cases and
it's just a wave of people being like
kyle's going to lose kyle going to lose
and then finally like you know i'm down
a hundred or so comments i see one guy
say who's going to tell them
they're suing the city and not kyle
rittenhouse
the lawsuit no one's no one so far
they're not suing kyle
the big money for anybody who wants to
sue is in the city and you know what i
agree
for the people uh so you've got what
like jacob blake's family
they're suing the police okay i don't
know about all that the guy was grabbing
a knife and fighting with cops that's a
that's an uphill battle yeah yeah say
the very least
but but for the the anthony hoover
they're suing i'm like oh yeah the
police should have been out there
stopping the riots so if they're if they
want to sue on that grounds i mean
that's a tough one though like the cops
should have been trying to stop the guy
from doing what he was doing
that was the crime no no no no if the
police were actually out stopping riots
there would have not been anything and
if hubert hadn't been rioting then there
wouldn't have been a problem well the
supreme court that's a good point
the supreme court ruled that police
officers have no duty to protect and
serve the the citizen so that's also
going to be something that's going to be
leveraged here i think because again
that's something that's that was said as
a president i think ian nailed it
actually i mean probably an uphill
battle when they're like we're suing you
and it's like well we maybe we should
have been protecting you but you were
the one doing what would need to protect
people from yeah right right now uh by
by nature being dead i think huber has
the best lawsuit against the city not
that that's saying he has a good chance
but
gage who's alive went on the stand and
admitted that he lied in his civil
lawsuits against the city by omitting
the fact that he had a gun with him that
he that he brought that and and that's
under oath he can never walk that
statement back i mean they're trying to
they're doing their little media apology
tour that he started the next day after
his testimony he's showing up on uh
michael strahan's show and then going on
uh some other show after he was on good
morning good morning america his first
show that he debuted on and they were
treating him like a celebrity
when his perjury charges coming exactly
i was just going to ask him i was going
to ask you guys is he going to face any
charges oh no no he's not going to get
perjury because it'd be the kenosha
county prosecutor's office let me uh let
me tell me you guys you know you're
you're a lawyer you're a recovering
lawyer tell me if if you think i'm on
point here
i think some of this is obvious
but uh here i'll speculate um
gage grosskroits had a second doi in
january of 2021 i believe it was six
days before the written house trial it
was dismissed on a motion of the
prosecution
uh gage grosskroyd's
had a uh assigned search warrants to get
a signed search warrant against him for
his cell phone that the prosecutor told
the police not to execute
gage um
seems like
you know he had this he also had this 10
mil let me slow down he did have i
believe was a 10 million lawsuit was
against the city or the police the city
uh i believe it was the city the city he
had a 10 million lawsuit against the
city over what happened
but then he testifies under oath
contradicting his own lawsuit which
clearly means he's going to lose so it
sounds to me like they went to him and
said you have two choices
you can plead the fifth move forward
with your lawsuit maybe win 10 million
bucks
and your second choice enjoy that money
while you're rotting in prison because
we're going after you with the full
weight of everything on your second dui
on your gun charge we're going to get
you an attempted murder of kyle
rittenhouse and he probably said i will
do anything you say yeah so there's
there's an interesting thing with
pleading the fifth um you have an
absolute right to plead the fifth in
criminal court and it cannot be used
against you you cannot draw a negative
inference from it in fact we saw that
binger just toeing the line of
mentioning
kyle rittenhouse's fifth amendment
rights almost got the case entirely
dismissed at that point in time
but when you plead the fifth in in a
criminal suit or in a civil suit with
pending criminal charges or anything
like that
the other party is allowed
to draw a negative inference from the
issue so if i ask gage the question uh
you know did you provoke this incident
incident and he says i plead the you
know i plead the fifth or did you bring
a gun to this i plead the fifth they're
allowed to draw the negative inference
that yes he did bring the the gun with
him or yes he did the defense cam yeah
the the the other party of the civil
lawsuit oh he's not criminal so right
the criminal and the criminal lawsuit uh
has to be ignored here but when you have
parallel suits you've got this criminal
case where he's a complaining witness so
he's basically a party along with the
state and then you have this civil case
if he pleads the fifth in that criminal
case then the civil case the city gets
to use that against him and so he was uh
the prosecutor may have made a deal like
that that's certainly possible and i i
think binger was out making tons of
shady deals and uh and various threats
to certain witnesses um and just
ignoring jump kick man entirely and they
knew who he was right the defense
actually came out said that withheld
from them yeah well to be fair when he
went into the the da's office asking for
a deal they all looked up at the ceiling
so they didn't know he was there yeah
you know right that was fine but but
yeah in in that case if he were to uh
plead the fifth in his criminal lawsuit
it would basically tank his civil
lawsuit because the city from a
prosecutor's perspective look i did it
too
you know your flex is to go to other
people and say i'm going to prosecute i
would go into a massive conspiracy and
be like here's 16 defendants who wants
to chirp
literally be like first one to me go
everybody else is going down because but
at that point i knew i had the evidence
i wasn't bluffing the case right i was
saying i can use some assistance and i
don't need to put 16 people away because
you also know that like not everybody is
as culpable as the next guy there's
different levels of it right so from a
prosecution's perspective not everyone
should go down for the same amount of
time just because they were involved in
the whole thing so that's where you get
some wiggle room i think this prosecutor
is crazy and probably just went in there
didn't have his case together and was
just like walking the big walk and
trying to say i'm gonna do what i want
i'm gonna pound my chest i'm gonna go on
tv i'm gonna make the world's greatest
case since oj except he you know i think
i think uh krause
tampered with all the evidence i don't
know if you saw my twitter throughout
about it it's it's speculative to be
completely fair but i think it's
speculative only in one key area what do
we know
the drone footage they admitted which
was their their their special key
evidence that showed kyle they claimed
to be pointing a weapon which it didn't
show by the way it was too blurry it was
nonsense but it came in a weird format 8
44. that was that was the it was it was
by 1920x84 so it was cropped
someone took footage that appeared on
tucker carlson
cropped at the top yeah presumably from
tucker carlson's show and removing the
uh the fox graphic
it was then further cropped and
compressed
renamed and sent to the defense
i think you know this stuff kraus has a
cropping software format factory and
compression software handbrake on his
laptop
so here's what i was talking to this
antifa guy and he said yo man like
that's wildly speculative for you to be
claiming that stuff and i was like well
hold on hold on hold on
evidence that was given to the defense
was cropped and compressed
the prosecutor who gave the evidence to
them that way has cropping software
specifically for cropping and
compression software which is
specifically it's transcoding but one
was like it does cropping and mixing one
does compression so look i'll put it
this way if i see a person on the ground
with a stab wound
and then i see a guy holding a bloody
knife
okay i'll admit it is me speculating to
say that guy with the knife stabbed the
person on the ground they call being
caught red-handed but i also think it's
fair to say the person with the with the
weapon in question that was used
presumably this same kind of weapon to
kill someone and they're right there
i mean i don't know if you agree with me
on that one well the the thing making it
even worse is uh whether or not krause
cropped the the footage and compressed
it one it was idiotic of them to use a
laptop that had anything other than uh
we saw it with the defense right and
during the jury deliberations they said
we have a clean laptop the only thing on
it is vlc
and the files that they need to view
that's it there's there's nothing else a
sanitized laptop and wha what's a laptop
that can play video cost 300 bucks you
can go you can go to target and buy one
um so you know that that's not a problem
why the state had a laptop with that
software on it along with other evidence
is baffling but the problem with it is
that kraus stood up and he said i don't
know anything about compression i don't
know anything about you know how you
manipulate these video files and then we
see because of their mistake of of
having this stuff on this computer we
see it there and it's like
look i know about compression i know
about cropping video i don't have
handbrake like
so so someone who has it you're like
okay why do why do you have this if you
don't know anything about it and and the
state shouldn't be manipulating and
cropping evidence anyway they send it
off to the crime lab to do that so it's
extra nonsense why can't we how come we
don't have leaders who are willing to
actually make a move
i'm talking about the judge here well
he's
he intimated putting the prosecution on
the stand under oath so this is what
this is on the spot this is well most
judges don't do that they can do that
this is what this judge should be doing
the trial's over right he can be issuing
uh instituting content proceedings on
his own there's no defense and
prosecution in that scenario every judge
has this right if he thinks to to your
point if he thinks someone lied that
appeared before him that's a content
proceeding against that person the nbc
news reporter person that was chasing
around the jury right
that in my opinion is one of the most
egregious things you can do is
intimidate a jury that's an actual crime
but let's set aside the crime what can
the judge do the judge can haul in that
person nbc news and say who gave you
that instruction to follow the jury what
was your instruction and what were you
supposed to do and if he lies contempt
of court and the penalty for contempt of
court is going to prison or he can find
you as much money as he wants to he
should be doing that he can how long
contempt how long can they send you to
prison for is it jail or is it prison i
think it's up to a year it's up to a
year per count yeah and then you can
stack them
and the judge just decrees it right
right and the money there's no real like
limitation i mean you can't go wild but
you can find a company a lot of money
for being held in contempt that's the
power that judges are supposed to wield
to keep these people in check especially
when prosecutors lie to their face but
when there's an acquittal this judge is
probably my guess just going to be like
well i'm not going to do anything
anymore when someone where where are the
leaders
there's no good when it's someone who
gets hit for contempt if they lie about
the same thing over and over do they get
a contempt charge every time every time
you can you can it's doable right that's
what's supposed to happen when
prosecutors bury or withhold exculpatory
evidence evidence of you know innocence
or doctor evidence the only remedy for
that is not the state or the federal
government bringing a case it's for the
judge to come in and say
i'm gonna hold you in contempt show me
why i shouldn't and as the judge likely
to say look
britton house is going home that's it i
gotta work with these guys look i've
been there they're gonna be there in my
chambers again and again and again if i
start a conflict that can't be resolved
i'm making my job you nailed it there
they are they don't want to deal with
the headache and i've caught prosecutors
in
massive narco-trafficking cases burying
evidence of innocence i waited a year
and a half till i got to the first
witness and trial and exposed it and got
those cases thrown out my next move was
like hey judge you want to issue
contempt proceedings this person lied to
you for 18 months and we just proved it
and the case just got tossed
and every time they're like well
uh let's talk about it later i got to
work with the us attorney's office i got
to work at the defense bar you know i
don't want to be out there when i got uh
uh falsely arrested i told you the story
off eric i've said it on air too many
times but when i got falsely arrested
when i was a teenager
i was told by the police the reason they
so uh long story short my brother and i
got attacked jumped and beat up by
security guards because of mistaken
identity or something that effect
when the when we talked to the cops they
said look
you know we know that you guys didn't do
anything wrong now everything's been
resolved but we got to work with these
guys you know they're a big part of the
economy here in the small suburb we get
calls from all the time if we get into
it the security guys it's going to be a
nightmare for us so we're going to let
them get away with the attack on you and
enjoy you know i hope you enjoyed the
eight months of your life you spent in
and out of court and all the money you
lost that's how it works
the state is friends with the state in
the system thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you